the gyro can experience even Trump like
even Trump like as much as he hates it
he has toned down a lot of his rhetoric
because of the criticism that he's faced
you know and that's it's important it's
very important yeah I mean he has the
that's one thing this virus is making
everybody have to do their job
mm-hmm like you realize like a lot of
his people were like acting in positions
like they weren't really truly vested if
you're acting in it but like it's making
everyone have to actually do their job
wondering if he would do it again
all over again if he knew how hard it
would be and how much he would get [ __ ]
on I don't you know I don't know I think
it was so funny when he presented to me
was like it was like like the hot new
nightclub you know what I mean and like
everybody was in there you know what
it's like like a nightclub and you could
pretend to be who you want to be and you
could just you know the mean and
watered-down expensive drinks and it's
just all happening then the coronavirus
comes and that's like when the lights
come on in the club and you get to see
you know our fucked-up [ __ ] really is
mm-hm and and so cuz when the coal
country just kind of like said I was
gonna go with Joe Biden regardless of
how loose it you feel he is or how sharp
you think he is when the whole country
was like was gonna go Joe you just made
me think like Trump is like a fancy a
nice resort like hotel and who doesn't
want to stay in a nice hotel right he's
like I'm rich from this and everyone's
like I want to do that but after a while
you get tired of spending 21 dollars for
Internet and forty dollars for pancakes
and you just want to go home and Joe was
kind of feeling it felt like he
represents home you know I mean like
people and I I feel like people Joe
Biden to me feels like a schoolhouse in
a third world country that's gonna
collapse and kill all the kids it's cool
houses made by people who skirted all
the rules of how tough construction
he's a old dude with dementia but I
think he's gonna be propped up by so
many different people who wanna vote
like President Obama's gonna come out
and endure something if he president
want to come out and take over
okay but if he doesn't you got Joe Biden
who's the leader of the country who
can't form sentences listen man there's
320 million people in this country
telling me that's the best the
Democratic Party can do that's crazy
well that's what I'm saying
what I'm saying is I feel like to
everyone he was nted home that's what
I'm saying because he's familiar he
wasn't standing next to the guy that we
all felt more comfortable with
especially in situations like this did
you see Obama's endorsement video
I didn't his straight up gas lighting
just gas it up you can find it I don't
know if we could play is it long or is
it look he knows Biden is doomed
he knows he's doomed so you think he's
gonna lose it's not a matter of whether
or not I think he's gonna lose I do
think he's gonna lose but even if I
thought he was gonna win he shouldn't do
the job he there's no way he can take
the pressure of that position with the
cognitive decline that he's already
showing but there's no buts
you just want the Democratic Party to be
back in control I get it no no I wish
listen man I wish like I say man like
when you and when you're in a nightclub
you don't care stuff's going down right
right but when you come out I don't
understand this nightclub but you
understand an analogy damn trying to
give you an example to me just the way
that Trump is handling having any kind
of criticism you get anything is
unsettling it's like dude just calm down
man like you got your big you're right
you're in charge it's kind of like I was
talking to Keith Robinson he had this
amazing point I don't know it just made
me laugh he said there should be some
type of test you have to pass to become
president because for any other thing
you have to take a test so you have to
have degrees or whatever but to be in
charge of everybody else and you're in
charge and you control the nukes
everything and it's like a backwards
thing and so that guy who's in charge of
everybody else is just it's like man I
just wish he didn't cause so much just
wasn't the way he he
you know I mean I wish he could just
take who he's always been asked my point
is so changed at all once he got into
office and people did expect him to yeah
he's always been the guy that if anybody
says anything about him he talks mad
[ __ ] about that yes never lied to geo
Donnell or whoever it is that he's been
infused with right he's never lied to
you in the way and so it's like you
respect all of that but it's just like
in times like this one is requires some
empathy many requires you to look in the
camera and say I feel for the people
that I not give me credit it's like
don't do to give me credit stuff now is
credit stuff is ridiculous and so I feel
like so what I'm saying is I feel like
having Joe come up there and play those
notes it feels like people how everyone
just all of a sudden overnight goes joe
biden's our guy it felt like I just I
think it's like when Carrie was on pills
and she couldn't sing the national
anthem because she forgot the words
can't be President he can't talk he
can't hold a sentence you give him a
couple minutes on CNN and he can't keep
it together but like after a year in
office dealing with international
politics the economy the environment all
these different things what I'm saying
is he's gonna have people show did Obama
but look how old he got how quickly by
Obama's brilliant Obama's a brilliant
articulate guy yeah sorry getting gray
hair his skin started sad because he was
actually reading the memos this is crazy
right that's my point
Biden starts reading those things to be
dead in a week and then who's gonna be
the vice president Elizabeth Warren who
they're gonna put in there no they're
probably I don't know who they gonna pig
is they they said he wants to pick a
woman of color so he said a woman of
color for Supreme Court said for the
vice president he should he should
should he or shouldn't pick the best
person he used to pick the best person
who will probably be a woman of color
why would it be a woman of color though
the most would it be because they're
underrepresented and it would be a good
thing for the country or would it be a
good thing for the country because it's
the best person for the job
both
the both best person for the best person
for the job I feel could be a woman of
color and the best country could also be
a woman of color it could be because a
lot of policies kind of stopped before
consulting with people of color and a
woman of color can see hey what we
leaving out this group let's figure this
out remember what if it's a male of
color who's better qualified for the job
I don't but that's not my point what is
what all the qualifications for this job
is what I just said there's no test you
have to take it's just a popularity
contest well if that's the case in what
but nobody so far a woman of color would
be would be what why would you want a
woman of color I think everyone would
just feel better a woman of color in
charge
hmm I I feel like what did Chelsea
Handler's say when she did her whole
thing remember she just she just did a
whole thing about something on Netflix
and she was like we and she went on
Ellen and said we need to start listing
in the women of color like it was like
yeah he probably should I think I'm not
the right person to be talking about
this but I feel like you know they say
Stacey Abrams is in the running and I
don't think she'd be a bad choice but
I've watched how she just puts things in
context and she is very smart and very
sharp and she is not thrown bike she
would be extremely qualified well I'll
tell you who could actually be a
resident who Michelle Obama she's not
going to do it no but if she wanted to
do it she could be President
why do you think she could do it first
of all she's brilliant she's articulate
she's well-known
she's she's a powerful person like she
speaks really well she obviously was for
for rather two terms she was the first
lady
so she's accustomed to the public eye
she's accustomed to speaking publicly
if dude if she stepped up and decided
she would run for president I think
she'd win by a landslide because the
possibility constant maybe not beat
Trump I should say but win the
Democratic nominee by a landslide
I really think you think
she would lose as well though I don't
know I don't know how it works it's
complicated right and especially when
you're dealing with electoral college
like look Trump lost the popular vote
but he won the electoral college vote
right and that's why they say Joe Biden
was the best bit because Joe Biden so
Pennsylvania it was a swing state and
Joe Biden is the only person out of the
Democratic nominees who did not say he
was against fracking he was like you
can't you can't be again you can't you
can't do it all at once and then they
they had they had the clip of the
fracking protest and he's like Oh vote
for somebody else man like Joe was like
go vote for somebody else and so Trump
they they were saying that Trump does
not feel like he could beat Joe in
Pennsylvania because that's what jobs
from and he also supports he has in with
you know the coal miners in the fracking
industry just like you know Trump so
when it comes to his electoral college
votes Trump doesn't know it knows he
can't beat him that's why I hints the
whole Ukrainian get some dirt on them
just announce something's happening type
thing that was kind of like the
narrative of that and so when it comes
to electoral votes that whole Midwest
game that whole Michigan Michigan is a
Biden is right there
and that's what I'm saying like the
people yes man oh no I don't know what
what's gonna happen once people start
hearing him talk on a campaign trail but
I don't you know I don't know how I
don't know how brilliant articulate
Trump is like I don't know I think I
think everyone as far as brilliance it's
a matter of being able to control crowds
and have these exciting rallies he does
arenas dude he does sold-out arenas and
he kills I know listen I'm not this is
not projective Lee I know you want a
Democrat to win right and you want a
woman of color to be the vice president
I would love that I would love for I'm
not saying I would love for things to
feel like their I don't want to say back
to normal but I would just love to feel
like when the president not be gay all
right now that it's not like those
horrible question questions Christian
you should yeah it's it's bad in those
ways but what I'm talking about is
his ability to excite his base and the
ability to get people behind him he's a
unprecedent ability and depending upon
how he handles this coronavirus crisis
they could swing left or right it really
depends entirely upon who Biden picks
because you remember when george w was
president it really was like president
dick cheney right dick cheney was in
that [ __ ] vampire underground bunker
yeah getting fresh blood pumped into him
every day and calling all the shots do
you remember there was one point in time
where cheney was consistently in the
bunker he was in the bunker for like
weeks at a time they were saying he's in
up they even told us he was in a bunker
but just in case anything happens like
why isn't bush in a [ __ ] bunker
he's the president dick cheney was out
there calling the shots me it was one of
the most transparent times you see the
connection between industry and
government where you have a guy who was
the former CEO of Halliburton a company
that rebuilds countries after we blow
them up getting no-bid contracts to
rebuild a country that we blew up while
he's making the decisions to blow up
these countries it's crazy it was great
it was crazy and why you couldn't stop
it
right but if someone comes along and
some powerful speaker someone who you
really mean there's there's several
choices apparently and if they pick
someone and I'm sure they're grooming
someone right now who you get excited
about you go okay this person this
person could step up even if Biden lost
or if Biden lost it right or Biden died
which is also possible bro there's a
there's a photo of him that was on the
New York Times yesterday where you can
see like where they gave him the [ __ ]
the face look he's he's talking and he's
like skin is unnaturally pulled up and
and back it's like oh Christ man maybe
twenty years ago maybe twenty years ago
but not now
this is crazy a man I don't know it's
like when he was talking about all the
stuff he would have done if this crossed
his desk like you know and just just
just like just having an awareness of
how the government works well what well
the what was it the pandemic agency was
closed down him up in trouble but well I
love about Trump he was on he's like
nobody thought to have what happened
like he literally
he just said it so he's like get rid of
him but then there's there's like all
types of protocols and you find out
where the money is for this like Joe had
it a just a knowledge of where all that
stuff was hmm and I feel like Trump
talks to his lawyers like what can I do
look I didn't sure what can I do we're
gonna do and he just goes you know then
he takes his stance based on what he is
known he's know he's gonna be protected
legally Brian he doesn't equate that
he's president of all of us you don't I
mean and so I just feel like that's
what's missing and he is incapable of
doing that I know when pence had the mic
and pants was getting popular it ate at
Trump he's like man let me come into
these how does that guy get popular
how does first of all you want to talk
about a vice prime with that guy's voice
sounds like well people were just happy
to hear somebody I'm not yelling back if
he was like we're gonna go have that by
the end of the week did you ever see
there's a woman who has one of them pink
[ __ ] hats on and there's a bunch of
people that are yelling impeach Trump
and Peach Trump and she's running like
gave president pens probably like job if
Trump gets impeached says oh she's like
yeah maybe we should not impeach him
like yeah maybe yeah yeah oh so funny
it's become so emotional right like and
and and I feel like Trump's a
businessman
so he he's not approaching this if any
emotion and it's just it [ __ ] with
people because they like you know well
the good thing that he did was block
travel from China that's a good thing
that's probably saved thousands of lives
really did a lot of people were saying
you're crazy for doing that but there's
also there's so many [ __ ] people that
are been saying that he actually didn't
they were saying that people that was
still coming from saying that so what do
you mean he actually didn't I don't know
I just heard that's what I'm saying I
was saying conflicting but they
definitely blocked he blocked travel
yeah but they were saying people were
still coming well maybe some people had
loopholes because of diplomatic reasons
right business reasons or whatever but
they did look man there was a video that
Eddie Bravo had on his page of Nancy
Pelosi in February telling people to go
out and go to Chinatown there's no
worries just go out mingle and then they
confronted her Chris Wallace confronted
her on Fox News and I was
just bullshitting our way out of this
while she was blaming the president it
look everybody got this wrong everybody
got it wrong yeah everybody did four
hundred thirty thousand people have
traveled from China to us since the
corona virus surfaced right but went but
the corona virus surfaced and this is
just a this I think this is just an
article about what yeah I understand
that the articles recent but this is an
article about when the corona virus
surface which was in January that's just
letting put its know how many surfaced
here made it over to America but that's
not how many people came to America this
is since Chinese officials disclosed the
outbreak on New Year's Eve in two months
after presidential also holds
restrictions forty forty thousand since
the president's impose restrictions he's
been right so what kind of restrictions
were those the bulk of the travelers who
were of multiple nationalities arrived
in January at airports in Los Angeles
San Francisco New York Chicago Newark in
Detroit all places [ __ ] by Corona hi
baby I was like what are you talking
about right now they flew directly from
rueland
[Applause]